au théâtre
lorsque le rideau se baisse sur une
production les décors peine trop souvent
le chemin du site d'enfouissement
une situation qui préoccupe la compagnie
jean duceppe
chaque production à la fin des airs
présente un conteneur donc une et deux
tonnes de déchets par production donc
entre 5 et 10 tonnes par année à
montréal selon écossais nos ce serait
près de 30000 tonnes de matériaux
utilisés pour des événements culturels
qui finirait au dépotoir chaque année il
ya des arbres qui viennent du d'un
plateau tournage de l'émission les
sapiens c'est à cette jeune entreprise
d'économie sociale que la compagnie jean
duceppe a fait appel pour les
accompagner dans leur virage écologique
faut d'abord refusé refuser les prêts
sont les problèmes pratiques actuelles
pour changer ensuite pour réutiliser
ensuite recyclés et valorisés et enfouir
donc ce nom lord et enfouir ça devrait
toujours être l'ultime option
ce désir de changer le quat'sous le lui
aussi mais ce virage bar gay avec son
lot de défis le premier dangereux c'est
vraiment quand on est à l'étape de
conception comme violents vis de faire
un écart écologique comme éco
responsable puis il ya aussi un anglais
pour réussir cette transition écologique
les théâtres doivent donc repenser leur
façon de travailler
on se rend compte ça prouve qu est un
peu plus de temps donc faudrait
peut-être revoir nos calendriers nos
échéanciers de pré production pour
arriver à temps la première avec un
décor éco responsable
mais ces changements peuvent s'effectuer
sans gonfler la facture au tnm ces trois
panneaux du décor des trois sages
avaient auparavant été utilisé pour la
pièce fleuve le moins de d'appel pour
enfouir matériel faut payer pour ça donc
l'aspect économique ou si elle
directement
il va avoir une économie sur les
matériaux mais un peu plus de dépenses
au niveau des salaires donc même temps
qu'à dépenser j'aime mieux et j'ai mieux
payé des gens qu'elle payait des
matériaux qui vont se faire enfouir
après cette approche deviendra-t-elle la
norme
si on met pas en place un nouveau
système d'économie circulaire dont on
n'est pas en train de créer des
conditions gagnantes pour que la culture
persiste de génération en génération
télé cinéma muséologie
tous les domaines devront à terme
repenser leur façon de faire pour
réduire leur empreinte écologique
un virage vert que plusieurs espèrent
voir créée en compte dans la relance du
secteur culturel dix inédits alexandre
chartier radio canada montréal